[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission consacrée
au thème de la liberté les libertés
d'expression liberté de penser à
l'occasion du festival de cinéma liberté
j'écris ton nom qui ce qui se déroule à
Marly-le-Roi dans lequel beaucoup de
films sur le thème de la liberté ont été
projetés dans lequel il y aura aussi un
palmarès qui sera prononcé dans quelques
dans quelques jours on va parler de ce
thème de la liberté pourquoi est-elle
tellement présente aujourd'hui pour en
parler Nathalie Wolf bonjour bonjour
Patrice cette date de conférence à
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
spécialiste du droit des libertés
Michel Antoine bonjour vous êtes le
directeur du du cinéma de Marly-le-Roi
notamment il y a d'autres cinéma dans
votre librairie
alors on a oui juste à côté de du
Fontenelle du cinéma à Marly on a on a
voulu
joindre à l'activité de cinéma à
l'activité de livre enfin de la galerie
donc et vous êtes l'organisateur de ce
festival liberté s'écrit ton nom et puis
avec nous deux étudiants à streetcombe
bonjour et Abdul Ken bonjour vous êtes
tous les deux étudiants au master de
droit public l'UVSQ et vous faites
partie du jury de ce festival de liberté
j'écris ton nom c'est bien ça totalement
donc vous avez vu tous les films
encore ce soir qui seront projetés ce
soir 25 octobre et vous allez devoir
dire lesquels vous ont le plus convaincu
c'est ça
vous êtes vous êtes des fans de cinéma
j'aime bien mais c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à moins y aller quand on est
jeune mais il y a toujours une bonne
ambiance c'est toujours sympa d'aller au
cinéma de découvrir des films enfin
c'est autre chose que de le regarder
chez soi
de ce qu'on appelle la crise de
fréquentation des salles qui
malheureusement je crois que ça fait 40
ans je croisais les salaudés aussi peu
fréquentés qu'aujourd'hui alors un mot
d'abord sur le sur ce festival vous en
avez eu l'idée après malheureusement je
dirais oui malheureusement oui après
l'horrible l'assassinat on était victime
Samuel patise compresseur
donc c'est une c'est quelque chose si
c'est imposé à nous que voilà avec la
ville mon partenaire principal et c'est
la ville de Marly et ça s'est imposé à
nous après ce
drame qui s'est roulait pas très loin de
Marly à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine donc
tout d'un coup on a eu envie de faire
une soirée et puis ça s'est transformé
en une manifestation de plusieurs jours
l'année dernière et finalement quand on
réfléchit le thème de la liberté
toutes les semaines il y a des films qui
sortent sur plus ou moins sur cette
thématique là donc un grand on pourrait
presque toutes les semaines consacré une
soirée à cette thématique là on peut en
trouver toujours un certain nombre donc
voilà donc on a voulu voulu le délai
dernière et cette année et je pense
qu'on le fera tous les ans
mettre à l'honneur ces femmes et ces
hommes voilà qui qui
se battent qui se battent
liberté j'écris ton nom parce que bon
par rapport
puisque on parle de cette assassinat de
sable petit je vous propose un petit
extrait d'un entretien que j'avais eu
avec un écrivain qui s'appelle David
dinotta qui est consacré un livre à ce
Zelda salicina le livre s'appelle j'ai
exécuté un chien de l'enfer c'était la
parole du terror c'était de l'assassin
rapport sur la signature le terme
rapport n'est pas innocent parce que il
y a eu aussi un rapport de l'éducation
nationale et David di nota montre
notamment que le hiérarchie d'éducation
nationale a carrément lâché Samuel Paty
ils sont expliquent dans cette extrait
la boucle que je décris c'est au fond
vous avez donc la situation quelqu'un
qui est pris en charge par des
islamistes et un référent laïcité qui
confirme la thèse de l'élève qui n'est
pas dans la classe donc qu'il aurait
effectivement
froisser ses élèves qui est une thèse
pédagogiquement absurde mais qui va être
c'est ça qui est incroyable qui va être
validé par le rapport de l'Inspection
Générale donc l'inspection générale
reprend la thèse du référent laïcité
donc je dirais presque valider
somnambuliquement sans se rendre compte
de la contradiction pédagogique que ça
représente parce que si effectivement
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure le
comportement d'un professeur dépend de
la sensibilité religieuse de ses élèves
il y a pas d'enseignement laïc possible
donc
l'inspection générale reprend
somnambuliquement la thèse du référent
laïcité qui en plus repose sur un
témoignage qui est celle de l'élève qui
était pas dans la classe
enfin en tout cas confirme ce faux
témoignage et va être pas pris
somnambuliquement par l'Éducation
nationale puisque l'éducation nationale
va s'appuyer sur ce rapport donc vous
avez une boucle incroyable aux personnes
ne s'aperçoit un que la thèse initiale
est fausse c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a pas
froissé ces élèves et deux que le fait
de lui reprocher ça est une
contradiction pédagogique
auteur de cette très très bon livre qui
est paru l'année dernière on cherche
midi
ça fait froid dans le dos
on va pas pour parler ici de de cette
affaire mais c'est c'est après cette
étape que vous avez l'idée de créer ce
festival alors on va commencer par le
premier thème avant d'aborder peut-être
les quelques-uns des films qu'on peut
voir au cinéma de Marly-le-Roi c'est le
thème de la liberté d'expression
[Musique]
alors en quoi cette ce thème de la
liberté d'expression je pose la question
à tous est-elle essentielle aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le socle de notre de
notre démocratie et je suis très très
heureuse que Michel antenne nous permet
de participer à ce festival parce que je
crois que c'est vraiment important
aujourd'hui de sensibiliser nos
étudiants qui vont devenir des acteurs
clés dans la cité ils vont être avocats
vont être magistrats ou être
commissaires de police juriste enfin
bref on a vraiment besoin
pas besoin d'eux il faut absolument
voilà les sensibiliser à ces sujets et
c'est un trésor en fait la liberté
d'expression c'est d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant qu'on regarde nos textes on
a la déclaration de droits
écoutez d'abord notre vie
il y a la déclaration de l'homme de 1789
c'est voilà notre notre socle et la
déclaration parle d'un des biens les
plus précieux de l'homme donc vous voyez
voilà on doit la chérir on doit la
protéger le droit international aussi la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
par exemple elle elle dit que c'est
l'une des assises de notre société
démocratique et elle se réfère aussi au
terme de bien l'un des biens les plus
précieux de l'homme donc on comprend
bien que bon on s'est battu très
longtemps pour pour la gagner cette
liberté n'oublions pas pendant très
longtemps c'était le régime de la
censure donc ça voulait dire que si on
voulait jouer une pièce de théâtre si
vous voulez publier un livre
un film à l'époque ça existait pas les
pièces de théâtre ou un livre il fallait
une autorisation préalable et on
contrôlait et bien a priori donc
aujourd'hui on peut publier tout ce
qu'on veut c'est ce que disait Voltaire
c'est
on a le droit d'imprimer de dire et bien
tout ce que l'on pense c'est le droit de
tout homme libre et c'est même aussi et
c'est vraiment c'est ça qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est un rempart
contre l'autoritarisme contre le
totalitarisme par exemple l'écrivain
Orwell George Orwell disait que
finalement la liberté n'a pas de sens si
elle ne permet pas de dire aux autres
tout ce que l'on pense et y compris ce
qu'ils n'ont pas vous envie d'entendre
voilà c'est ça la liberté d'expression
se battre pour que des gens puissent
exprimer des opinions qui ne sont pas
les vôtres c'est ça sinon tombe dans une
seule chose dans un récipient d'accepter
d'accepter la contradiction et l'opinion
aux différentes exactement c'est c'est
pas si facile et ça veut dire aussi que
la liberté en tout cas c'est comme ça
que notre droit à la définit c'est aussi
pouvoir alors bien sûr diffuser des
idées inoffensives accueillies par tous
mais c'est aussi pouvoir choquer heurter
voir voilà avoir des propos choquants il
reviendra peut-être après mais voilà il
y a un phénomène qui est assez
intéressant c'est à dire que on a
l'impression notamment avec les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut dire n'importe quoi
c'est donc il y a une liberté absolue
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
j'ai pas mis celle où vous que cette
liberté existe ou pas qu'il faut quand
même la protéger
elle est relativement
est-ce que c'est aussi la liberté la
liberté devient n'importe quoi oui je
pense que là tout le monde se
l'approprie elle est beaucoup elle est
bouclée
mais d'ailleurs même la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme elle dit on peut tout
dire mais à condition de pas abuser de
son droit c'est ça la limite il y a le
respect de leur public le racisme c'est
puni par la loi c'est pas inopinion donc
il y a quand même des limites qui sont
posées d'ailleurs en France on n'a pas
exactement le même système qu'aux
États-Unis et ça avait été très discuté
d'ailleurs quand les les
révolutionnaires vont écrire la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et les
constituants on va on va hésiter est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on va dire qu'on
peut tout dire c'est ce que vous voulez
d'ailleurs Robespierre il voulait une
liberté absolue d'ailleurs après il a
coupé la tête et il a coupé la tête
voilà c'est ça l'histoire a été faite
la liberté
et ensuite c'est devenu à quelqu'un de
sanguinolent
pas vous avez raison de dire on n'a pas
la même conception que j'ai les
Américains dans la dans la
dans la règle même de fondement même de
de
des États-Unis il y a cette liberté de
pouvoir dire absolument tout il y a pas
de poursuit même il y a quelques
restrictions quand même dans le premier
amendement mais beaucoup moins qu'en
France et nous on a quand même posé un
certain nombre de limites et la limite
c'est que on peut pas dire comme ça
avait été le cas par exemple une
ex-candidat du Front national avec
comparé Christiane Taubira à une guenon
bah voilà ça c'est du propos raciste
Eric Zemmour dans un discours public en
2019 dit
tous les musulmans
sont responsables des vols des viols et
même des attentats voilà ça c'est un
propos que la justice condamne on est
dans du discours de en revanche quand on
se moque de la religion des religions
quand on dit qu'une religion est conne
voire une religion est plus conne qu'une
autre ou quand on fait des cartes bien
sûr
et la différence elle est pas toujours
facile à comprendre aujourd'hui et sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est ce qui est
terrible c'est que chacun peut dire tout
ce qu'il veut anonymement avec des
contrôles qui sont qui sont difficiles à
mettre en place
des réseaux sociaux mais avec une
certaine précaution à publier
aujourd'hui avec une certaine
autocensure puisqu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui nos propos peuvent être
relayés en masse on sait qu'aujourd'hui
on peut être attaqué sur les réseaux
sociaux comme ça a été le cas durant
l'affaire Mila alors qu'elle a
simplement
usé de sa liberté d'expression et
aujourd'hui la liberté d'expression elle
est elle est très enfin si vous voulez
la limite est très fine entre le propos
qui sort de la liberté d'expression et
ce qui ne sort pas de la liberté
d'expression alors si vous voulez quand
on s'exprime on a aussi cette cette
crainte de sortir parfois de la liberté
d'expression ou dire tout simplement ce
qui n'est pas socialement admis parce
qu'il y a ce que dit le droit mais il y
a aussi ce que la société attend de nous
et ce qu'on peut dire ou pas vis-à-vis
de la société donc il y a aussi ce
jugement si on peut dire un petit peu
aussi médiatique et de la population
tout simplement et il y a en effet plus
des règles sur le négationnisme sur le
racisme sur l'antisémitisme
sur l'homophobie également
discriminatoire et alors ce qui est
difficile avec les réseaux sociaux bah
vous Patrice vous êtes soumis à des
règles déontologie en tant que
journaliste et la difficulté c'est que
les internautes ne sont pas soumis à ces
mêmes règles
c'est ça qui est difficile c'est que le
droit est toujours un peu en retard au
fond par rapport aux évolutions sociaux
technologiques aussi mais
pour en venir enfin
la raison pour laquelle vous avez fondé
ce festival donc la mort de sabule petit
on peut dire aussi que c'est
cette team font de la liberté
d'expression une certaine façon
il semblerait
par rapport aux propos de Nathalie ce
qu'on hier soir on diffusait la bataille
des droits de l'homme qui avait réalisé
Caroline forest il y a presque 15 ans
maintenant et on voit à quel point
finalement
d'un pays à l'autre donc elle filmait
voilà la conférence d'Urban en 2001 elle
filmait
la suivante qui avait lieu à Genève etc
donc on voit comment d'un pays à l'autre
finalement cette liberté de s'exprimer
de ce comporter et complètement
différente donc et finalement ce
qu'elles montrait dans le film c'est que
les coalitions de pays qui ont des
intérêts voilà et voilà
en commun finalement pas sur le sur le
corps des droits de l'homme sans aucun
par rapport à des décisions et
finalement aujourd'hui
on se rend compte oui que les pays les
plus démocratiques sont pas à ceux qui
ont en dernier mot oui oui
c'est ça dans le monde aujourd'hui il y
a plus de 21 pays démocratiques ce qui
est
dans ce qui est quand même un vrai
problème la France a une spécificité
justement comme le disait Michel dans
dans cette protection de liberté
d'expression oui je crois que vraiment
et c'est dommage parce qu'on a tendance
en rougir aujourd'hui et à ne pas
défendre suffisamment notre bien
précieux on a un modèle qui est je crois
très très protecteur qui est protecteur
d'abord de la liberté le juge en France
il est très libéral par exemple quand on
regarde les différents procès
aujourd'hui de films qui sont attaqués
donc je regarde par exemple dans les
arts ou le le la chanson le rap etc
heureusement on a un juge français qui
est très libéral et qui va le plus
souvent rejeter les recours qui sont
portés dans les devant les juridictions
à part tout un tas de gens qui ont été
choqués heurtés par une œuvre d'art donc
en France on a un système très
protecteur et la liberté d'expression
elle marche aussi avec une autre liberté
c'est la liberté religieuse la liberté
religieuse à la française avec cette
spécificité française c'est la laïcité
et cette laïcité souvent les gens se
disent allez voilà
la laïcité va et là pour embêter un
groupe religieux déterminé empêcher les
croyances
pas du tout elle a été conçue vraiment
comme un si vous voulez un outil qui au
contraire protecteur de nos libertés
vous savez par exemple Victor Hugo qu'il
a beaucoup défendu il était très croyant
il a beaucoup défendu la laïcité il
disait l'église chez elle les tâches
chez lui mais lui-même était croyant il
écrit dans son dans son testament et ça
a été pourtant un fervent défenseur de
la laïcité donc là la laïcité elle
protège aussi et c'est ça que peut-être
les voilà certaines personnes
comprennent pas bien aujourd'hui tout
simplement parce qu'on peut être qu'on
explique assez bien ou parce que c'était
la laïcité elle était très longtemps
comme l'air qu'on respire c'est
tellement naturel que peut-être que nous
nos générations et générations de nos
parents ont eu tellement l'habitude de
cette laïcité qui vont peut-être pas
bien expliqué
aux nouvelles générations et pourtant
elle est protectrice aussi des groupes
religieux et des gros religieux
minoritaires voilà c'est très
intéressant
la loi de 1905 il y a eu des combats à
ce moment-là et puis pendant très
longtemps il y a pas et vous qui êtes
juriste vous vous démontrez même pas eu
de procès c'est autour de la lessive
très longtemps et puis aujourd'hui et
comme sur la liberté c'est un peu la
même chose on sent que il y a des
problèmes il y a des limites il y a des
choses qu'on ne peut peut-être pas dire
il y a aussi de l'autocensure dans les
libertés
c'est intéressant quand même justement
dans cette atmosphère donc que je
décrivais où on a l'impression qu'on
peut tout dire il y a quand même
aujourd'hui peut-être des problèmes qui
ne se posaient pas il y a 10 ou 15 ans
oui je crois
même des arts puisqu'on est là pour
parler d'art justement
parce que je trouve que c'est voilà
c'est de toute façon c'est toujours les
heures qui ont été attaqués en premier
et même au 19e siècle si on regarde les
grands procès littéraires par exemple
Baudelaire il a été condamné lorsqu'il a
publié Les Fleurs du Mal il y avait
quelques poèmes très sulfureux c'est
pareil pour Flaubert etc donc les airs
sont toujours au premier plan et
aujourd'hui moi ce qui est un petit peu
et je crois qu'il faut vraiment porter
notre attention sur cette évolution
c'est que les censures elles viennent
plus de l'État c'est pas l'état qui
comme avant censuré elle émanent de
manière assez diffuse
de groupe dans la société des groupes
politiques des groupes économiques des
groupes religion et ça c'est perçu quand
même intéressant qui est le phénomène de
dépossession du droit c'est à dire que
si vous prenez le phénomène me too c'est
vrai que c'est plus droit qui est le
dernier juge et peut-être en matière de
liberté c'est un peu ou de laïcité c'est
un peu la même chose c'est plus c'est
plutôt
sur soi-même ou c'est plus l'état qui
qui est au centre de ça enfin je crois
que c'est plus le droit en tout cas ce
qui devient inquiétant c'est que il
faudrait pas que certains je crois
malheureusement on est déjà là-dedans
que certains artistes certains
intellectuels certains professeurs même
nous non je suis pas sûr qu'on enseigne
la même manière ce qui serait la pire
des défaites je crois ce serait qu'on
soit tous censure et là si on arrive à
ça je crois que ce sera vraiment très
triste Michel c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
il y a plus de il y a eu des affaires de
censure de cinéma
on parlait de censure les Américains là
le plus grand pays de la démocratique
c'est à instaurer un code voilà pour
que les baisers ne durent pas 10
secondes il fallait que ça dure trois
secondes pour que les eux ça existait
mais c'est vrai que on a plus besoin de
code aujourd'hui les les groupes de
pression existent suffisamment pour non
il y a plus de pratiquement plus de
censure
on parle beaucoup de la Russie qui est
réussi
voilà qui était bon ukrainien a mis en
prison par Poutine voilà du s'exiler
pour faire voilà pour continuer à faire
du cinéma il y a certains pays
tous ces réalisateurs qui filment
clandestinement ou voilà ou qui ne
peuvent pas certains pays où être
cinéaste relève d'un courage absolu
aujourd'hui
dans le pays qui ne sont pas
démocratiques justement mais je parle de
la France en France il y a plus de sens
pratiquement plus de censure d'État
un peu ce qu'on veut et voilà dans tout
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
genres on va dire de cinématographique
aujourd'hui les les auteurs peuvent
s'exprimer mais
il y a des classification
mais peut-être
là on va aborder dans quelques instants
le festival mais juste en transition
peut-être que il y a aussi les les
cinéastes s'interroge aussi sur leur
propre liberté enfin peut-être
qu'il n'utilise pas tous totalement
parce qu'il y a des sujets sur lesquels
on se dit vaut mieux pas intervenir quoi
je sais pas cette impression là mais oui
on en revient toujours à finalement
l'objet de ce qu'on a envie de filmer ce
qu'on a envie de raconter mais
moi je trouve que le la liberté dans le
dans le 7e art dans la manière de de
réaliser de produire aujourd'hui on est
quand même
on est quand même pas trop mal en France
par rapport à à d'autres États quoi
alors on va passer bah justement à ce
festival liberté j'écris ton nom
[Musique]
je voulais vous demander donc vous êtes
vous êtes juré dans dans ce festival le
cinéma c'est quelque chose qui vous
tient à coeur vous avez accepté parce
que c'est intéressant il veut aussi ce
thème de la liberté qui vous est cher
puisque vous êtes étudiant master
pour ma part personnellement le cinéma
c'était face au festival c'était une
occasion de renouer avec le cinéma c'est
pas des lieux effectivement des cinémas
c'est pas des lieux que je côtoie très
très souvent effectivement c'était une
bonne occasion d'assimiler effectivement
le droit avec le cinéma enfin voir le
droit comment le droit est perçu
finalement par les réalisateurs et
comment il écrit en pratique finalement
et c'était assez intéressant c'était une
très bonne expérience très enrichissante
parce qu'on a tendance à le voir façon
très théorique à la fac et là ça nous
permet à travers un film donc c'est
aussi un élément de culture de voir
aussi comment est la comment évolue à
travers les pays à travers les siècles
les générations et du coup c'est hyper
intéressant de pouvoir diversifier ses
points de vue aussi j'avais vu combien
de films là à peu près depuis le début
on est au 4e le 5e
[Musique]
alors on voit pas donner non on va
aborder quelques des films qui sont qui
ont été diffusés mais il y en a qui ont
touché vraiment ils ont marqué il y a
parfois comme ça des films en sort de la
projection on est plus tout à fait le
même
au contraire aussi il y a des films on
pensait que ça allait au regard du sujet
nous prendre finalement et finalement
pas tant que ça en sortant de la séance
on s'est dit bon finalement ça a pas
marché pour moi ça a marché pour mes
camarades mais pas pour moi Michel c'est
vous qui avez choisi les les films oui
oui bah oui oui je programme les salles
de manière générale mais le le cette
sélection oui on
tel quelques mois avant
en prenant d'abord en essayant de
montrer les films sont pas sortis on
garde toujours un peu ce côté
événementiel avec l'exclusivité donc là
on avait quand même des films comme la
conspiration du Caire qui sortira de
demain
beaucoup de nouveaux novembre vous
n'aurez pas mal l'école est à nous alors
l'école est à nous de Alexandre
cassenetti c'était un hommage vraiment
au métier de métier d'enseignant pour le
coup alors si vous voulez on peut
prendre quelques uns des films comme ça
on va voir une bande-annonce après alors
d'abord on va commencer par vous n'aurez
pas ma haine ou vous parliez de qui
viennent ridoff avec notamment Pierre de
la Longchamp et Camilla Jordana qui est
qui est tiré du du film du livre pardon
d'Antoine Lewis
qui est donc l'histoire qui se qui se
passe pendant le pendant les partir du
Bataclan je propose de voir la
bande-annonce
[Musique]
des explosions des fusillades et une
prise d'otages semble-t-il à l'intérieur
d'une bataille d'une salle de concert
[Musique]
vendredi soir vous avez volé la vie d'un
être avec sa vie
l'amour de ma vie la mère de mon fils
[Musique]
mais nous sommes plus forts que toutes
les armées du monde
vous voulez que les peurs que je
sacrifie ma liberté pour la sécurité
[Musique]
pour faire tout ça
pas été l'unanimité pour pour nos
camarades mais c'est vrai qu'il est
hyper bien enfin ça montre vraiment
enfin pas on l'a pas vécu mais on
comprend à travers les émotions qu'il a
aussi tout l'impact qu'on les attendent
aussi derrière aussi sur la
reconstruction sur sa reconstruction
personnelle celle de son fils et du coup
ça ça montre aussi l'envers du décor
parce qu'on parle beaucoup du Bataclan
des événements donc tel mais peu de la
presse et là ça demande vraiment à toute
la maison
qu'il écrit au terroriste
c'est une adaptation vraiment de ce
qu'elle a fait vous n'aurez pas mal
enfin c'est ce qui dit au terroriste
m'avait vraiment vraiment comme beaucoup
de gens ému parce que là c'est c'est
vraiment c'est c'est voilà un acte de
résilience en direct écrit comme ça
juste après mais non le le film enfin à
mon sens est vite quand même de tomber
dans un espèce de patoche etc
il est toujours sur le fil et comme le
film sortait prochainement je trouvais
quand même indispensable de pouvoir le
le présenter voilà on fait une sélection
de toute façon entre
les différents
films de différents nationalistes
nationalité mais mais après on reste
toujours sur le voilà sur sur cette
thématique qui est le
autour de la liberté et donc voilà les
attentats les attentats de novembre ont
été directement liés à
ce sujet là et puis c'est vrai que oui
c'est ça c'est des vies qui ont été
détruites et des vies des proches aussi
qui qui sont évidemment touchés par ces
attentats et d'ailleurs procès
qui fait aussi partie de la
reconstruction peut-être enfin c'est
important pour les aussi pour les
victimes
bien sûr c'est la fonction du même du
procès et d'ailleurs il y avait dans
l'extrait que vous avez passé une une
des dernières phrases comment ne pas
enfin comment conserver nos libertés
tout en tout en assurant la sécurité
c'est un peu voilà tout tout l'enjeu
aussi
qui s'impose à nous et de savoir où
placer le curseur se protéger et en même
temps ne pas ne pas anéantir toutes nos
libertés c'est très difficile c'est un
sacré en jeu un sacré défi pour le
législateur c'est qui nous représente
donc pour nous
autre film alors ça c'est je voudrais
bien avoir votre réaction là-dessus
parce que au fond c'est l'histoire d'une
prof qui un moment je vais laisser
fermer les élèves ce qu'ils veulent
c'est l'école est à nous d'Alexandre
Castagnetti
[Musique]
voici votre nouveau professeur
mathématique madame Thévenot
prépare-toi parce que les élèves en
maths ici c'est pas des flèches
je vous présente
c'est la bonne note tu mets 18 mois il a
tout le monde cette trimestre ça veut
dire que même moi j'ai 18 mois
[Musique]
la majorité des professeurs a décidé de
se mettre en grève je peux assurer la
permanence pendant la grève je vous
propose de faire un truc de faire un
moment au collège c'est de faire ce que
vous voulez après ça reste l'école ce
que je voudrais c'est que en face comme
si l'école était à vous on a le droit au
comptable madame et ben oui
vous pouvez pas prendre ce genre de
liberté ils sont ici pour travailler bon
sang de venir c'est bien non bien ceux
qui sont contents
à ce qu'ils font
[Musique]
on n'est pas dans la France a du talent
merde
[Applaudissements]
bon on arrête tous bazar il y a le
brevet à la fin de l'année vous prenez
pour qui en fait le guide suprême vous
pensez que vous avez le droit de décider
de l'avenir d'une ado à la place de ses
parents
j'ai fabriqué une couveuse pour avoir un
poussin
si tu veux couver
il y a eu beaucoup de comédies sur
l'école pas toujours très fine non alors
celle-là celle-là moi je la recommande
là c'est d'abord c'est drôle souvent
drôle mais c'est quand même il y a un
vrai message de de porter des questions
par Sarah souko par cette enseignante
qui essaye d'intéresser les donc c'est
ces jeunes à venir à passer le portail
de l'école voilà c'est un peu le c'est
un peu le thème du film c'est à dire
profite d'une greffe pour pour comment
dirais-je essayer de faire sortir chez
chacun des élèves une envie une passion
de faire quelque chose c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment assez assez réussi j'aime
beaucoup et c'est aussi prenez-vous en
main quoi
ça vous a touché
vous êtes dit que c'est tiens ça serait
bien une école comme ça
où il faut un peu plus d'autorité
il y a beaucoup d'utopie mais
personnellement je trouvais que c'était
un très bon message je trouve que c'est
un film qui peut se regarder à plusieurs
à plusieurs niveaux quand on est quand
on est enfant on peut simplement voir ça
comme un film drôle mais quand on est
adulte on peut voir ça plutôt comme une
réflexion sur finalement le système
éducatif et ce finalement se décrocher
de cette de cette espèce de pression qui
nous pousse à aller vers des études
supérieures si finalement notre passion
n'y est pas finalement si on n'a pas
l'envie et la passion de faire ses
études là plus tard faire autre chose et
qu'on peut être tout aussi bon en
faisant en faisant autre chose du moment
qu'on est passionné intéressant on
pourra aller aussi tout aussi loin
finalement et c'est ce que ce film nous
a nous a montré finalement c'était
c'était vraiment très beau à avoir
Astrid
de voir que bah c'est vrai que les
élèves ont souvent en tête le fait de
valider l'étape supérieure le brevet le
bac il n'y a pas vraiment d'intérêt et
on se retrouve souvent à pas trop savoir
ce qu'on veut faire et là du coup bah
entre guillemets cette grève ça leur
permet de vraiment voir ce qu'ils
veulent faire et de se poser les vraies
questions pour aussi leur avenir donc
c'est aussi intéressant de voir qu'il y
a système alternatif qui peut aussi
exister et qui peut rendre aussi les
élèves heureux et leur accorder une
place dans la société quoi donc la
preuve que vous êtes
pas vu encore
justement comment qu'est-ce que c'est on
s'est dit qu'est-ce que c'est
transmettre exactement et avoir un cadre
[Musique]
et puis essayer de faire sortir chez
chacun alors c'est un peu différent moi
j'ai des étudiants mais je crois que les
questions se posent encore également
quand on est étudiant à la faculté c'est
de faire sortir chez chacun et bien on
étincelle et trouver aussi ce qui peut
passionner et parfois on a des on
développe des passions assez tard ça
peut arriver moi j'ai vu des des élèves
assez mauvais au collège lycée puis
devenu étudiants
se révèle et tout à coup
et heureusement on a le temps aussi
voilà la vie est pas forcément une
autoroute on peut prendre des chemins de
travers et puis on peut aussi avoir
plusieurs passions qui arrivent bien
plus tard heureusement que la vie comme
ça d'ailleurs j'ai pas demandé parce que
vous exprimer très bien
c'est quoi votre projet vous avez envie
de faire quoi après vos études
et là j'ai découvert à pas longtemps le
bureau des affaires juridiques et
libertés publiques du ministère à
l'intérieur donc peut-être que j'y serai
pas mais justement par un stage
c'est important de enfin de participer
je pense que c'est vraiment là où il y a
aussi tous les enjeux tous les gens
sociétaux actuels et je trouve ça
important de les pouvoirs les comprendre
et pouvoir y participer aussi parce que
pour moi il y a quand même clairement un
peu une urgence autour de tout ça et du
coup pouvoir les participer enfin j'aime
bien
mettre de conférence à l'Université
enfin devenir enseignant j'y suis
réellement attaché tout simplement parce
que bah j'ai reçu énormément de
bienveillance de la part de mes
professeurs depuis plus jeune beaucoup
d'encouragements et c'est ça tout
simplement que j'aimerais retransmettre
et faire aimer l'école tout simplement
aimer l'université mais l'école et
transmettre le savoir la connaissance la
passion voilà
c'est du boulot alors on va passer à un
film qui est qui sort aussi de c'est
aussi la conspiration du cœur
qui est l'histoire d'un fils de pêcheur
qui intègre la universités à Lazare du
quai qui est l'épicentre du pouvoir de
l'islam sunnitain c'est ça
on en reparle après
[Musique]
je donne tout ça va se retrouver au cœur
de la lutte du pouvoir entre les
religieux la politique c'est ça
c'est la négociation entre le politique
et le religieux en Égypte sur le dos du
peuple tout simplement donc des libertés
alors on est en plein dedans c'est
formidable quoi c'est c'est moi je
trouve
mieux que ce soit le film qui remporte
la palpe pour moi mais non non
le film qui a remporté
le mieux sa place dans la sélection
cette année parce que là on est vraiment
dans un pays où la politique
comment on essaye d'influer sur le grand
imam de façon à ce qu'il fasse pas trop
de de d'ombre et qui soit dans dans le
cadre imposé par le politique par le
justement c'était vraiment un très un
très beau film et qu'ils avaient
beaucoup apprécié ce film là
donc voilà même si vous allez pas au
festival elle le voit
les voir c'est de conseils de Michel
antenne il faut le suivre parce que il
connaît bien alors
on va parler d'un film on avait parlé
tout à l'heure de vous n'aurez pas mal
qui est tiré dans de réalité
c'est-à-dire les attentats du Bataclan
autre film qui est tiré d'un d'un fait
réel c'est midi fraîche les engagés vous
nous rappeler peut-être Nathalie le le
contexte enfin de oui c'est
un film faire en choisissant 2018 de
mémoire
ou plusieurs personnes cette personne
avait été jugée parce que ils avaient
aidé des migrants à passer la fruitière
entre l'Italie et la France donc on est
dans voilà dans la partie des Alpes et
en effet l'un d'entre eux a été détenu
en détention provisoires ensuite voilà
tout ce qui ont été relaxés en appel
mais c'est vrai que ça pose la question
de ce que les journalistes ont appelé le
délit d'entraide enfin c'est pas un mot
qui existe
parfois choqué enfin disons voilà
quelqu'un qui aide un type qui risque sa
vie et qui est condamné quoi un jeune
d'un jeune gamin même qui est-ce que sa
vie et qui contenait ça fait choqué
finalement le droit a fini par rejoindre
la morale si je veux dire
en plus
toujours après difficile parfois de de
déterminer l'âge de la personne mais
c'est vrai que c'est un mineur et c'est
vrai que c'est la question de
l'hospitalité qui nous oblige tous qu'un
devoir qui est posé et ensuite et voilà
et le droit va évoluer après et va
finalement abroger une partie des
dispositions une partie de de cette joie
qui figure dans le code des étrangers du
droit d'asile et va si vous voulez oui
supprimer ce délit de solidarité lorsque
on est on aide quelqu'un qui est déjà
sur le territoire et qu'on le fait dans
un but uniquement humanitaire sans
contrepartie
notamment l'excellent Benjamin Lavergne
faisait une randonnée nocturne
rencontre du risque que tu as pris David
crever dans le froid et je suis allé le
ramasser
tu sais ce qu'il a traversé
plein de pays
[Musique]
vous sortez du véhicule s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
vous avez besoin de bénévoles comme nous
sert à quoi en fait
c'est pas juste un mot
c'est pas s’engager ça c'est se mettre
hors la loi
[Musique]
tu es arrivé là
on nous dit qu'on est des hors la loi
parce qu'on vient à porter secours
mais qui peut accepter ça
[Musique]
dans un monde civilisé la solidarité ne
devrait pas être un délit
[Musique]
un film d'Émilie fresque qu'on
connaissait plus comme auteur romancière
elle avait fait elle avait participé au
scénario du film d'Arcadie 24 jours
d'accord donc non mais là je crois que
c'est son premier film c'est assez c'est
assez impressionnant c'est beaucoup de
maîtrise dans sur un sujet qui
casse gueule on va dire mais
là voilà la solidarité ne devrait pas
être un délit dit dans les dans la
bouche de Catherine yagel de la comédie
franc française il y a de la Comédie
Française en Suisse
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un film vraiment très
très fort aussi et c'est fort parce que
c'est
quelque chose qui nous avait
vu ce type
c'était quand même vous n'avez pas
encore vu parce qu'il est projeté ce
soir
si on pousse un peu plus loin donc
l'hospitalité puis la question des
migrations les migrations qui devrait
s'amplifier avec le réchauffement
climatique aussi par des déplacés
environnementaux et comment on fait là
aussi c'est toujours une question du
curseur entre ce devoir d'hospitalité
qui nous oblige voilà c'est c'est un
devoir le Conseil constitutionnel a
consacré le principe de fraternité
justement à la suite de cette affaire et
en même temps il y a aussi des réalités
économiques politiques très concrètes
avec des États qui ont aussi des
difficultés à accueillir et comment où
est-ce qu'on peut associer
[Musique]
les frontières et ceux qui veulent enfin
qui est plus frontières et ceux qui
veulent au contraire les exercices et
les renforcer donc où placer le curseur
pour être à une fois dans le respect et
bien de l'humanisme et puis en même
temps être ne pas être dans de tomber
dans un angélisme complètement à côté
des réalités donc c'est ça l'enjeu
encore et c'est ça qui est bien avec le
cinéma c'est qu'au fond
c'est le premier essentiel celui de
l'immigration etc mais ça nous le montre
dans la façon dont c'est vécu par des
individus c'est ça c'est ça qui fait qui
est debout dans le enfin
il y a beaucoup de documentaires en ce
moment
on a passé un qui que je recommande
aussi ils avaient la combattante la
semaine dernière sur une ethnologue du
Darfour Marie-José tchubiana et voilà
qui qui passe la dernière partie de sa
vie à faire des papiers pour des des
exilés politiques mais non non bah la
fiction oui permet plus incarnés
dans une fiction c'est pour ça que on a
besoin que tous les jeunes alors la fac
de droit mais aussi de toutes les de
toutes les autres universités viennent
au cinéma lisent des livres parce que la
fiction complète aussi tous les savoirs
qu'on peut qu'on peut transmettre il y a
la magie de l'art qui fait que on a
vraiment besoin de cette entreprise
croisement des disciplines et d'être
toujours tourné vers les arts c'est
vraiment ce qu'on essaye de faire de
faire comprendre à nos étudiants ça
marche c'est aussi de l'objet de cette
association entre la Faculté de Droit
voilà et et un festival de cinéma
c'était vraiment de
l'objets en Algérie oui
ce que vous avez souhaité
et il y a des il y a des débats déjà
entre vous
vous allez vous réunir un peu par la
suite pour on en a parlé légèrement on a
eu des petits débats des petits
désaccords et puis c'est ça qui est
intéressant les désaccords surtout
vous êtes un vrai jury
consensuel
vous êtes dans le jury non non pas du
tout
c'est une expérimentation cette année
voilà avec un jury jeune voilà donc on
refera tous les ans je suis sûr alors on
va passer peut-être dernière partie de
cette émission profite de votre présence
ici
pour aborder peut-être la question de la
crise du cinéma est-ce que oui je vais
quitter pour faire court
merci Patrice voilà exactement merci
Patrice de votre invitation et merci à
Michel Entei encore d'organiser ce
festivalent
on va parler de justement de la crise du
cinéma
[Musique]
propose de devoir un extrait d'une
interview vous avez faite avec un de vos
collègues qui s'appelle Luc boucan qui
est directeur du cinéma 7 à Élancourt
qui justement j'ai posé cette question
de la crise du cinéma
les plateformes ne nous ont pas fait du
bien du tout surtout que il faut
rapprocher ça je pense du problème
peut-être aussi du prix des places qui
est quand même devenu relativement élevé
une famille de quatre personnes
sujet bien comprise c'est à peu près 9
10 euros par mois
c'est 10 11 euros est-ce que c'est pas
un petit peu trop cher je sais que
certains militent pour ce soir encore un
petit peu plus cher en allant vers le
Premium etc moi c'est pas mon avis mais
bon les avis sont partagés je pense
aussi que les plateformes pour pour en
dire de mots très rapidement
draine aussi tous les scénaristes c'est
à dire qu'il on monte on manque de
scénariste dans le cinéma et ça se voit
ça se sent là je regardais un petit peu
ce qui sort l'année prochaine les trois
mousquetaires vous voyez encore une
version des Trois Mousquetaires alors
j'espère qu'elle est réussie il y a
Vincent Cassel
on en a quand même vu un certain nombre
déjà donc il y a ça je pense aussi qu'il
y a un problème d'offre de film c'est à
dire que oui je crois que
a pas de de ce changement d'habitude
d'ailleurs j'ai regardé moi aussi enfin
c'est le monde a fait un gros papier
là-dessus j'ai regardé les chiffres
Roomba la vie le film du boss il a fait
200000 entre pas terrible
canaille avec José Garcia François
Cluzet qui est tout simplement
moins de 60 000 entrées je crois enfin
bon une catastrophe catastrophe et en
même temps alors ça c'est le côté
catastrophe et c'est vrai qu'il y a il y
a des films comme la nuit du 12 qui sont
des films d'auteur plutôt de ou revoir
Paris qui ont bien marché quoi
absolument non mais c'est vrai que il y
a il y a un public pour la recette de
toute façon qui est fort dans nos salles
mais c'est vrai qu'on manque de
locomotive même moi je suis très content
que l'année du 12 ait trouvé son public
parce qu'en plus il est sorti un très
bon film sorti en plein milieu d'été
c'était quand même un sacré Paris pour
Dominique moelle et son équipe
l'habitude de sortir des films avec son
premier film c'est sorti en 15 août et
avait fait un succès
absolument et donc là on a eu aussi pour
prendre le contre-pied on va dire du
film de Dominique molk personnellement
j'ai beaucoup aimé Top Gun Maverick qui
a été un gros succès mais qui à mon sens
n'a pas eu le succès qu'il aurait dû
avoir si on avait pas ce problème de
fréquentation des salles
alors voilà bon une analyse qui est
l'assiette vous partagez on a tous là
notre analyse alors c'est vrai que il y
a eu la crise du du covid forcément qui
a joué les gens plutôt eu l'habitude de
rester chez eux y aller l'arrivée des
plateformes ça c'est la première
explication mais elle est un peu elle
est un peu courte peut-être non
on a du mal à
percevoir les vraies raisons des
affections qui s'est quand même qui
s'est enclenché oui pendant le covid on
a vécu un traumatisme on en sort
doucement
mais bon je veux dire la crise endémie
du cinéma vous l'avez connue comme moi
depuis 50 ans il y a eu l'arrivée des
télés
enfin des années 80 il y a eu la vidéo
etc donc à chaque fois
la salle de cinéma s'est adaptée
oui bon j'entends le prix etc le prix
moyen en France dépasse pas 7 euros les
gens qui payent les gens qui payent une
place
d'abord et voilà il y a un Français sur
deux qui va pas au cinéma donc voilà sur
la la le reste
voilà on a eu une
très belle fréquentation jusqu'en 2019
2020-2021 2022 ça sera évidemment trois
années difficiles très très difficile
donc voilà il faut il faut reprendre le
mot le mot que tout le monde emploie en
ce moment c'est reconquérir le public
donc comment on s'y prend en ce qui me
concerne je reste persuadé que la salle
est créatrice de d'une valeur ajoutée
que dans dispose pas les plateformes
donc moi je travaille là-dessus voilà
sur des séances sur des festivals sur
des séances qui qui sont qui sont pas
qui sont pas lambda où on essaie de
voilà de créer de la valeur le
rappelons-nous quand même que la salle
de cinéma c'est dans beaucoup beaucoup
d'endroits ça reste le seul le seul
que l'endroit qui crée du lien dans un
dans un environnement dans une ville il
y a rien après 20h à part quelques cafés
quelques restaurants donc
l'endroit ouvert toute l'année après 20h
c'est le meilleur moyen de c'est le
meilleur endroit de pour rester seul
dans le noir pendant 1h30
qui disait effectivement c'est c'est la
promiscuité dans le confort de
l'anonymat c'est un peu ça non non voilà
moi je pense que on sort vraiment d'une
période difficile on aurait dû préserver
peut-être au même type au même titre que
le livre on aurait dû passer je pense la
culture en bien essentielle le théâtre
le cinéma c'est vrai que le livre c'est
plus simple on était chez soi mais
voilà donc c'est oui c'était plus
compliqué c'était aussi donc moi je
reste confiant que les gens vont revenir
maintenant bon il y a des il y a des
débats sur le type de film qu'il faut
qu'il faut sortir le public est toujours
un public plutôt jeune le président de
moins en moins
le travail qu'on doit faire et on en
parlait tout à l'heure c'est de de
permettre et de motiver les 12-25 ans
pour qu'il revienne un peu plus au
cinéma non ce public là c'est c'est
évaporé clairement
au même moment les plus de 45 ans
redevenait cinéphile c'est dans les
années 2010 etc donc ce qui a permis à
la fréquentation de se maintenir
des films dit d'arrêter ça fait des
films de
créatifs enfin de de créateur quoi
on va pas raconter des histoires là SS
oui enfin en France on demeure le pays
de la cinéphilie on a des gens on peut
voir plein de films mais
les les trois succès cette année ce ne
sont pas des films les trois films dans
les 10 premiers cette année ce sont des
films américains donc on a encore besoin
des Américains pour remplir ça mais on a
un système de financement du cinéma qui
est qui nous a quand même servi qu'il
faudrait préserver
le soutien au cinéma en France et
c'était comment
ça reste quand même très vertueux pour
pour défendre la création dans dans les
salles et il faut le oui il faut le
préserver merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur je rappelle
aller de toute façon même si vous allez
pas ce soir si vous pouvez déjà ce soir
avec Emily fresh qui aura la diffusion
du de son film les engagés des engagés
et un débat par la suite et puis et puis
aller au cinéma alors vous êtes vous
êtes à Marly vous êtes ailleurs aussi
dans le 78 oui on est à la maison la
Chatou Chatou et Vaucresson et on gère
également l'Eden à un moment aussi cinq
salles indépendantes
merci beaucoup d'être venu et puis je
revenais qu'on vous voulez vous êtes
chez vous ici merci à vous et puis à
très vite pour de nouvelles un nouveau
numéro de Paf merci
[Musique]